greetings drill seekers
this is the rider's ridge the republic's
stomping ground
from here you can meet like-minded
writers
manage your career
[Music]
learn to nail those wild moves
stay stylish share your creations with
the republic
stay on top of the latest news
and take up some ferocious multiplayer
action like free for all or tricks
battle
our six versus six team competition
so here's how it works performing big
tricks on the modules will turn them
from red to blue
and every trick that you stop will
contribute to your team's overall score
still with me okay when your team has
turned all the modules blue
you capture that district which will
help multiply your score into the big
time
progress progress progress to unlock
more content you gotta burn those stars
so if you want to be the boss of your
own career
the world's most famous competitions are
waiting for you
[Music]
[Applause]
now some might say the best parts of the
republic can be found
in the city playground we've got modules
that you can slay for days
[Music]
maybe you're all about living on the
edge
either way to progress you've got to
earn those stars
having the right rig is important too
we've all got our preferences
all right i get it sometimes you just
want to explore
and bathe in nature
that's right everything you do counts
getting those stars means more
rad to be had and the republic will
abide
there's always something awesome to do
as you reach new milestones and unlock
more challenges it's the red bull
joyride people
it's infamous it's spectacular it's the
biggest stage of slope style mountain
biking
and guess what you can play it versus
your friends
[Applause]
there is so so much more
more stunts
more sports more events
[Music]
just more okay and the natural
outdoor playground for you and your
friends to enjoy
any way that you want
[Music]
when we say fun with everyone we mean it
look at all these riders
does this speak to you then don't miss
out on mass
races
the republic awaits you ryder see you
[Music]
soon
[Music]